y sigue luchando minuto a minuto lograr
esa mayoría de 218 votos que necesita
para que pues sea el próximo presidente
de la cámara de representantes
recordemos que los republicanos ganaron
la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes con 222 votos versus 214
de los demócratas los demócratas mañana
en esta votación que se llevará a cabo
al mediodía en la plenaria del Congreso
votarán todos en contra de macarthy Y
entonces macarthy tienen un amplio un
margen muy pequeño de republicanos que
se que voten en contra de él para Pues
el poder llegar a esa mayoría de 218
votos lo que pasa es que pues esa ala
radical de republicanos que quiere
medidas mucho más severas pues ha dicho
ya abiertamente cinco derechos al menos
cinco republicanos al menos han dicho
que no votarán por mccarthy mañana y
esto Pues no le permitiría mccarthy
lograr esa mayoría de 218 votos por eso
es que está haciendo todo tipo de
concesiones para el ala republicana
contar con ese apoyo que necesita de
estos simpatizantes de Donald Trump que
llegaron a la cámara de representantes y
están pidiendo medidas mucho más
extremas nunca la historia de Estados
Unidos se había presentado que pues un
candidato a la presidencia de la cámara
de representantes no lograra esa mayoría
Y si esto ocurre pues lo que pasa lo que
pasará es que se harán votación tras
votación hasta que se logre esta mayoría
de 218 votos y se puede elegir mañana un
presidente a la cámara de representantes
la concesión concreta que hizo macarthy
para lograr esta este apoyo del ala
radical es pues que les dijo que sí no
les gustaba en su gobierno como
presidente de la cámara representantes
cualquier cosa pues estos radicales
podían Llamar a cualquier votación para
reemplazarlo